bape trois lettres pour découvrir l'
architecture à travers des lieux de
patrimoine des colloques ou encore des
expositions la première biennale
d'architecturé de paysage de la région
ile de france ouvrira ses portes le 4
mai prochain à versailles un moment de
réflexion autour de ce thème l'homme la
ville et la nature
la grande interrogation aujourd'hui et
du moment en terme d'urbanisme
c'est le mariage entre la nature et
l'urbain et ça c'est devenu une question
prioritaire contenu de la préoccupation
écologique et donc tous les architectes
ou les urbanistes pensent différemment
depuis le début ce nouveau millénaire et
ont mis la préoccupation
environnementale au coeur de leurs
travaux durant soixante et onze jours le
public pourra notamment à découvrir six
expositions réparties sur plusieurs
lieux au château de versailles
au potager du roi dans les écoles
nationales supérieures d'architecturé du
paysage le choix de la cité royale pour
accueillir cette biennale s'est presque
imposé de lui même
la m ici dans cette école d'architecturé
cette école du paysage dans cette avenue
de paris où il y aura une lime qui sera
ordinaire et expositions photos la
relier au château de versailles ou
potager du roi ça faisait du sens
et puis évidemment nous avons à
versailles des centaines de milliers de
touristes ce qui fait des centaines de
milliers de visiteurs potentiels pour la
biennale
lors de ce rendez vous le public pourra
également découvrir les projets les
ambitions du grand paris express lors
d'une exposition au sein de l'ancienne
poste